let us begin this morning with the mtv
movie and tv awards that were handed out
last night euphoria won four awards with
lead actress zendaya bringing home the
trophy for best performance in a show
castmate sydney sweeney accepted the
dramas award for best show jack black
nailed his entrance when he came on
stage check this out
[Laughter]
he received the comedic genius award
yeah there you go there you go look at
that impressive stunt work
and we also got to show you an emotional
jennifer lopez who's honored with the
generation award she thanked the people
who gave her joy and also guys she also
thanked the ones who broke her heart and
the ones who she said lied to her and
made her stronger yeah when she said who
told her you're not gonna make it this
isn't good for you yeah that does fuel
you it does it really really does the
things that hurt you the things that uh
challenge you yeah the things that make
you stronger that's what she was talking
about jennifer let me just say that mtv
is a division of our parent company
that's paramount global yours make sure
we get that